mr brown thank you for joining us on the
program this morning um he's shouting in
the wind aren't you because the
government is not going to take any
notice
well look i'm standing in the cold
actually and it's been a cold night it's
going to be a cold weekend
and people are afraid to turn up their
heating because of the heating bills and
we're really dealing with that real live
situations where people are having to
choose between the food they buy and the
heating costs they have to face and
we've got to do something about it you
cannot leave millions of children
perhaps five million children in this
country in poverty
going to school sometimes ill-clad
sometimes hungry and something has got
to be done and i think the chancellor
forgot last week about that group of
people in our society who simply cannot
afford the bills they're having to pay
at the moment
and he's got to take urgent action to do
something about it and i want to see the
faith groups the churches the
foundations the charities mayors local
authorities all coming together to say
to the government look we have got to do
something about the condition that
millions of children and particularly
families but also some pensioners are
facing as a result of this escalating
rise in heating bills from friday this
week
when you were running for re-election
though back in
2010 your chancellor alistair darling
said that you'd make cuts i'm quoting
that were deeper and tougher than
margaret thatcher's in the 1980s
isn't that what the government is having
to do now they're going to have to make
those cuts because of the amount of
money that the pandemic has cost us as a
nation
no no and we had a winter fuel payment
for pensioners we had child tax credits
and we were continuing to give
families in need about 80 or 90 pounds a
week extra to meet their bills we
weren't cutting back on the benefits
available to people or the child benefit
child benefits gone down by 20 since
2010 the value of all benefits are
falling as a result of inflation rising
we're dealing with a completely
different situation here
when the government is cutting benefits
at a time
when the need is greatest and while we
introduce a winter fuel payment for
pensioners you're going to have to do
something about families generally in
this country who simply as i say we we
helped um with the local charity i'm
involved in we helped about 400 families
a few weeks ago and put 50 pounds on
their pre-payment gas and electricity
meter but we can only do so much uh
we've got a warehouse in in lock elliot
and fife where we're collecting things
from amazon and other firms that are
helping us uh give goods that can go to
families that are in poverty and that's
home furnishings but it's also nappies
it's also toiletries and it's also of
course uh going to be food as well and
we're working with all the food banks
but even all the goodwill in the world
and all the charity and all the work
that voluntary organizations are doing
can't bridge that gap which only the
government can do between the needs that
people have and the income that they're
receiving and you cannot raise benefits
by only three percent when inflation is
eight percent food inflation is ten
percent heating inflation is fifty
percent you've got to deal with the
situation here and now this is an
absolute crisis in living standards and
we're going to have the highest level of
poverty amongst children that we've seen
for 50 years
worse than in the 1980s when it was mass
unemployment that caused it now it's low
pay and low incomes that families are
receiving
but looking at the statistics um under
labour in
2010 the percentage of people in the uk
in absolute poverty after housing costs
was just over 20 percent it's 18
at the moment so you can extrapolate
from that that that late people were
worse off under a labour government
no you're completely wrong because child
poverty it went down one and a half
million under a labor government it's
now gone up to three million four
million it's going up to five million
under the conservatives look i keep
saying to you that child poverty is
worse than it was in the 1980s it's
going to go up from 4.3 million this
year to 4.8 million during the course of
this year and then it's going to be on
go beyond 5 million and the reason is
obvious we've cut the value of child
benefit by 20
in the last 10 years we've had benefit
cuts in seven of the last 10 years you
cannot keep taking this money away from
families
and then giving them huge heating bill
rises and then expecting them to pay for
the food shop which is going up in cost
we've just had the bread and milk are
going up as well
and expect people to be able to to fend
for themselves poverty is far worse now
than it was in 2010 i can tell you from
my own experience locally but i think
everybody who's listening to this
program knows that
there are you once you were of course
previously chancellor before you were
prime minister and you famously once
said there are two types of chancellor
those who fail and those who get out in
time do you think wishy sunax missed the
boat
i think you look i praised that sonic
when he did the furlough scheme and
i i wanted to be able to support
everything we're doing when we've got a
national crisis but you cannot support
the lack of compassion and the lack of
understanding about what's happening to
people in their real lives you know
we've got mothers in in fife where i am
who cannot afford a cucker
and therefore they can never give their
children hot food
i had a family that i uh
the cottage my family center was working
with where three children were sleeping
under one sheet they didn't have a bed
and they didn't even have blankets or
duvets now we are appealing today
for companies that can give us duvets
blankets and help with that sort of
heating
equipment that would allow people to
protect themselves against continuing
cold nights by the time we get to
september and we face another winter
with heating bills going up again the
crisis will be even deeper now no
compassionate chancellor can fail to
understand what is going on in the
despair that exists in the communities
that they just don't visit and the
desolation in the faces that quite
frankly they never see
do you have a thought on the police
fines
for events taking place in downing
street during the pandemic and the fact
that 20 fines have so far been issued we
are led to believe with more to come and
what that says about the culture in
downing street at the time
look i've got a thought about this when
people are suffering
when during the pandemic
people were not able to be at the
funerals of relatives and
my case and other cases
when people were making huge sacrifices
we had parties going on in downing
street and i think there was even a
party last night
what we've got to understand is the
government has a responsibility to all
the people of the country and if they
ask people to do things they've got to
be prepared to do things themselves and
take some moral lead and of course
that's what's been missing in the last
few months
talk to me about at the ochenton report
of course we've not got it yet but what
we do know is that several hundred
babies died that should not have died
because they weren't cared for properly
and then they weren't listened to after
their babies died or suffered from brain
damage i know that it's a subject that
is very close to your heart so i i am
aware of the sensitivity but i wondered
if you had a thought for those parents
and other you know would-be parents new
parents who are about to go into
hospital to have their babies
but no no family recovers from the loss
of a child
it leaves you um
grieving uh for the whole of your life
it's very difficult to come to terms
with that and if there have been
mistakes
and if people have uh
failed to listen to families after
the deaths have occurred then that's
something that really has to be remedied
quickly so there's going to have to be
new rules new standards but
i haven't seen this report i've got to
wait to see that report and so will
everybody else but what we know is
people are at the most vulnerable when
they have a
a child that they've longed for
who then dies within a few days it's
something that
no family should have to bear
and um of course as we know you and
sarah dealt with that with dignity and
and respect and i'm
i appreciate you taking the opportunity
to talk to us about that amongst other
things this morning i will let you get
in from the cold thank you for joining
us this morning mr brown
thank you